um let's talk about density this is
something you and i have been working on
for years now
um and by working on i mean investing in
and being on the board of
um what attracted you to density in
terms of we know what
your thesis was in terms of computer
vision but
in terms of the founder and where the
company was at and then
uh take us into the journey to get them
where they are now which is
uh kleiner perkins just did a it's very
public a big round of over 50 million
dollars
the company has major customers they've
been very public about that take us
through that journey
of working with a founder with you know
i think when you
got involved it was low single digit
employees to now
yeah so as i mentioned we're interested
in the idea of how
compute power interprets the physical
world
there has to be a software service
attached to that most people think
cameras
i think cameras are a small part of how
compute power works
so we think about microphones sensors
uh infrared laser radar
you know all the ways of interpreting
the physical world um
i was introduced through jonathan
trieste yep
from ludlow ventures he's a fantastic
investor everybody loves detroit
out of detroit everybody loves working
with him and interestingly he was
i mean talk about a mensch he would when
he was just had this venture from he
would just sponsor
the launch festival when i was trying to
get it off the ground after i broke up
with techcrunch
and mike and he just was like hey listen
i'll just i'll give you 10 15 grand just
to sponsor and i was like
what do you get out of that he's like
supporting you i was just like oh man
that's so nice
he he is the classic definition of the
word bench
and he's been a real pleasure to work
with and when
someone like jonathan says to me mark
you have to meet this founder
yeah you know i always talk about
introduction and signaling and all these
things and why they're so important and
why they're matter like jason if you
called me and said mark you have to meet
this founder
i'm going to drop things and meet the
founder and uh
and jonathan did that you know and he
knew that i was interested in the
category
and i met andrew very early incredibly
impressive
also a menchie person and he had
a theory for what he thought was going
to be
a privacy compliant way of tracking
people moving around office buildings
and spaces
and i bought into the thesis and we look
at what's happened with the uyghurs in
china and using cameras to track
you know uyghurs moving around for
nefarious purposes
and you look at the pushback that i
think modern society will have against
camera invasion of public spaces and
workspaces
i think non-camera solutions are going
to do incredibly well
so he had an idea for how to solve that
you know i met some of the team he was
attracting i always say there's two
things i look for jason in a company
really early
cadence of shipping product can you ship
and the second is cadence and quality of
attracting team members
and those are the two biggest tells for
me and so when you get guys like garrett
bastable who was out of apple
who worked on the apple watch who had a
ton of experience in how to source and
design
and build uh products at scale
cross-border
and that person wants to then join
andrew and his mission that's a really
big
tell when you look at the founding team
grazioli and a bunch of the people who
work at density
and how they had followed andrew for
five years on this mission and they
really
he attracts and retains incredibly
talented people both those things were
important to me jason